the u.s and china have announced a plan
to work together on cutting their
emissions in the next decade the world's
two biggest greenhouse gas emitters
unveiled an agreement at the un climate
summit in scotland that includes plans
to reduce methane output phase out coal
consumption and protect forests though
light on solid commitments the pact
could send a strong signal to some 200
other countries at the cop 26 climate
talks
announcing the agreement u.s special
envoy john kerry said china and the u.s
may have their differences but
cooperation on climate was imperative we
also expressed a shared desire for
success at this cop
on mitigation
adaptation
support
and frankly all of the key issues
which will result in the world raising
ambition and being able to address this
crisis
now with this announcement we've arrived
at a new step
a road map for our present
and future collaboration on this issue
so john kerry says the u.s and china now
have a road map for taking action
chinese leaders have been noticeably
absent from cop 26 but china does have a
chief climate negotiator there and he
also spoke of the important role the two
countries share
china and the us shoulder special
international responsibilities and
obligations
we need to think big and be responsible
and we need to work in line with the
global trend and work hard to promote
world peace and development
we need to actively address climate
change and through cooperation bring
more benefit to both our two peoples and
people around the world
cutting coal will be key to china's
emissions reduction targets but the
country is still expanding its use of
the fossil fuel most of the country's
energy comes from coal and china is the
world's largest producer and consumer of
it
our next report is from the city of
datung in changshi province which is
considered the capital of coal mining in
china
at first sight there's a sea of wind
turbines blanketing the surrounding
terrain
but this is dartong china's coal capital
the city is so steeped in the industry
it even has a museum dedicated to its
history
people have been mining coal in dartong
for nearly 1500 years
but as china tries to rid itself of
fossil fuel generated energy
many here are uncertain what the future
holds for them and for the mines
maybe there won't be any in the future
how would so many workers and their
families survive without coal
lee is a miner in dartong like several
generations before him he lives from
coal production
his son has followed in his footsteps
like in dartong some 900 mines in shanxi
province employ hundreds of thousands of
people
for many it's hard to imagine a life
without them
where can we go then i have no other
skills and benefits i can't live
anywhere else if i'm going to die i'm
going to die here there's no work to do
in other places
for now workers aren't too concerned
china's struggling to shake off its coal
addiction and there's little sign of
those jobs drying up
china's ramped up investment in wind and
solar energy in recent years but it's
still heavily reliant on coal to meet
its massive power demands
coal makes up around 60 of the country's
total energy use and over the last
decade it has consumed more of the fuel
than the rest of the world combined
last month authorities ordered mines to
boost coal production by nearly 100
million tons to battle a power crunch
threatening china's economic recovery
from the coronavirus crisis it's also
needed to ease an expected energy supply
shortage for winter
china has pledged that coal consumption
will peak by 2025
but drastic reliance on the fuel source
to meet energy demands has raised doubts
about whether that's feasible
what will happen after after the peak
is as important as when the peak will
happen
are we going to see a long plateau and
if so that's probably not great news for
climate change or are we seeing a steady
decline or a drastic decline if china
fails to cut coal out of its energy mix
in time it will be all the more
difficult to achieve its bigger goal of
net zero emissions by 2060.
i'm joined now by julio friedman from
the center on global energy policy at
columbia university dr friedman is one
of the leading experts on carbon removal
dr fredman welcome china is a major
polluter as we've just heard heavily
dependent on coal how optimistic are you
that its agreement announced that cop26
to boost climate cooperation with the us
will yield the results that are needed
i think that this announcement is a
triumph and i know that the
diplomats and state department officials
working with their counterparts in china
have been discussing this for seven
months
uh and it is a necessary step in order
to get the world to a net zero economy
so much of the focus is understandably
here on what governments can do to
reduce carbon emissions but can carbon
capture technology on the other side of
this equation really be effective in
tackling the problem
absolutely
it's noteworthy that among the topics
highlighted in the u.s china agreement
carbon capture technology was one that
was singled out and the reason why is
because we cannot reach our net zero
commitments without it neither the u.s
nor china or many other countries
and not just for the power sector really
for the heavy industrial sector is where
carbon capture technology will be
important
another thing that was highlighted in
the announcement was direct air capture
which is one of the many ways you can
remove co2 from the air and oceans
that technology
is beginning to enter the marketplace
but again requires a great deal more
investigation and support but the
science is clear and the technology
works
so but the technology to remove carbon
from the oceans and the atmosphere is in
its infancy as you say you said that
this needs to grow as an industry that
to be twice as big as the oil and gas
sector within 30 years is that realistic
who pays for it and if it is realistic
on that time scale wouldn't that that
not be too late for us
well we know the recipe to get this done
we've done the exact same thing with led
lights we've done the exact same thing
with batteries we've done the exact same
thing with wind and solar
the recipe is a combination of
innovation
and market aligning policies and private
investment
and those are all beginning to happen in
this space whether or not we get there
in enough time is really up to us but
there is nothing in the physics or
chemistry or politics that naturally
prevents this outcome
what are the risks of carbon capture and
storage as we look further down the line
could using co2 storing co2 underground
just leave the problem for future
generations when we don't know what that
cost will be
uh i think that is a misunderstanding of
what carbon capture is and how it works
um it is a radical departure from
business as usual
uh and in point of fact we have been
putting co2 in geological formations
with zero incident and with zero leakage
for over 50 years
uh it's quite the opposite actually not
doing this technology path in fact will
unquestionably burden present and future
generations uh if we take direct action
now the earth will eventually mineralize
all the co2
and
essentially
return
the carbon to the earth exactly
where it came from
dr friedman from columbia university
center on global energy policy thanks
for your time
my pleasure thank you
you